the one question we get asked the most
is probably what should I invest it and
we're tempted to share hot tips about
music hey seriously put your money there
and you can't lose but instead we
usually just say it depends investing
should always be looked at through your
personal context what might be a sound
investment for your bestie might be
totally inappropriate for you so if
you're considering dipping your toe into
investing and wondering where to start
the first step is to ask yourself five
important questions before putting any
money on the line when confronted with
an investment opportunity
most people wonder how much money
they'll make when the more appropriate
question is how much am I willing to
lose if you have a thousand dollars to
invest how would you feel if you lost
100 of that 200 500 now if the thought
of losing money at all makes you sweat a
little you're not alone loss aversion is
the term psychologists use for our
tendency to fear losses more than we
enjoy gains it's why many investors sold
off their holdings during the market
crash of 2008 they overestimated their
risk tolerance when times were good and
ended up selling at a loss when the Seas
got stormy knowing your personal
threshold for this loss pain even
short-term is a great start to knowing
what kind of investment is right for you
the second question you should ask
yourself is what is the goal or purpose
of this investment is it for your
retirement for your child's college a
trip around the world each of these
goals probably has a completely
different timescale if your goal is far
into the future
you could probably handle a more
aggressive long term investment option
like this
market or real estate and take on more
risk that way you can leverage the
longer time line and put yourself in the
position to receive the maximum reward
while also allowing yourself space to
recover from a recession but if you were
just a year or two from your investment
goal a dip in the market might mean you
can't afford to pay for that goal so
you're probably better off sticking with
something less volatile like a CD or a
bond fact one of the habits in Stephen
Covey's classic seven Habits of Highly
successful people is begin with the end
in mind and nowhere is this more true
than in investing as you consider your
goals you should ultimately make a
decision on the circumstances that would
lead you to selling the investment this
helps you avoid selling in a panic or
hopping from one greener pasture to
another for example you might decide
that you plan to own an investment for
at least 10 years or that you'll get out
if the investment loses 10% knowing
these details in advance will help you
both pick an investment with realistic
goals and help you keep your head if the
news headlines get hysterical it's okay
to allow your rules to be a little
flexible but having no plan at all can
lead to your decisions being driven by
emotions like greed fear or panic many
brokers and investment companies are
notorious for hiding fees or making them
super complicated so it can be tricky to
figure out exactly how much an
investment costs sometimes there's a
simple one-time fee like a stock trading
service that charges per trade mutual
funds and index funds on the other hand
charge you a percentage of the money you
invest every year and perhaps even an
extra sales charge in the form of a
front-end load an investment advisor
will typically add an additional fee
layer for the service so if you hire one
be sure they're providing plenty of
value even investment options that
appear to be free like CDs and
high-yield savings accounts come with
opportunity costs they are reinvesting
your money into higher paying
investments and pockets the difference
free investment offs like Robin Hood
generate income by earning interest on
whatever cash you have in your account
that isn't currently in an investment to
be clear paying a price to invest isn't
bad or even something you can always
avoid just make sure you know what
you're paying so you can decide for
yourself if you're getting your money's
worth it would be find but all your
money on a single roll of the dice if
you certain of the outcome but in the
real world there is never a sure thing
spreading your assets out and avoiding
fuller concentration can help ensure
that your fate isn't in the hands of any
single company sector or industry for
example let's say you have most of your
savings in the stock of the company you
work for what would happen if your
employer suddenly went belly-up you not
only be out of a job but that money you
were counting on for retirement would
evaporate a financial advisor might
recommend selling off some of that stock
and diversifying elsewhere like buying a
home or opening up an IRA remember that
2008 crash many people had the bulk of
their net worth tied up in their homes
and couldn't afford to ride out the
storm
balance is key so whenever you're trying
to decide on a new investment consider
how it relates to the rest of your
assets if there were a one-size fits-all
that worked for every person in every
situation it would make our jobs a lot
easier but picking the right investment
doesn't have to be as overwhelming as
you might think asking yourself a few
basic questions can go a long way to
simplify which choice is best for you no
matter what surprises might be around
the corner and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description if you'd like to
support us on patreon we want to hear
from you tell us the story of your first
investment in the comments
[Music]